stefan mitzner is a kidney specialist at
the rostock university clinic
he studied here when this was still part
of east germany
even before the fall of the wall we were
at work in the main research division of
the clinic for internal medicine in
rostock
it's always specialized in kidney
disease dialysis and renal replacement
therapy
that's what rostock was known for and
attracted students for myself included
as a student mitzner observed doctors
development engineers and well-trained
clinic and lab personnel all working
together on their research
it's true that the renal medicine in
particular had a very good reputation
because of the active clinical and
research program here
that served as a model for the entire
eastern bloc
both in terms of quality and quantities
mitzner was still a student when the
wall fell
there was little sense of change inside
the clinic
but it was different outside on the
streets yeah this is when you boarded us
this is a building many people here know
from the days of the peaceful revolution
this was the state security headquarters
in rostock and it was a target of the
monday demonstrations that we had here
much like the ones in leipzig
mitzner and his fellow students joined
in
state security photographed and filmed
the demonstrations
the students didn't know that but they
were worried their careers were on the
line
the fall of the wall turned out to be a
big stroke of luck for mitzner
it gave him new opportunities to start
developing an artificial liver one of
his first trips to the west was to a
symposium on the subject
in a way the symposium was decisive
it was an eye-opener for the rostock
group
because our goals were already very
precisely formulated
in terms of the development of this kind
of organ for example
but the solutions were just not feasible
in practice
one result of this symposium was that in
the car and train coming back
we started coming up with our first
ideas about what we could do better
a few years ago the researchers in
rostock presented their artificial liver
for cleansing blood of toxins
now it's the world's most widely used
device when it comes to saving people
dying of liver failure
meanwhile scientists are working on
another dialysis process for use in
cases of blood poisoning
initial clinical tests on patients have
yielded positive results
if not for the fall of the berlin wall
stephen mitsner is certain he wouldn't
have come nearly as far as he has in his
work